this is what much of Srinagar has looked
like for nearly two weeks
Kashmiri is unable to move around the
largest city in the region and
communications completely shut down
indeed administrators say some phone
lines in the Kashmir Valley were
reconnected on Saturday with more due on
Sunday we have also opened up mobile
internet with some functionality in at
least five districts and shall be
successively and in a calibrated manner
opening up other areas as well phone
users in Srinagar had buried reactions I
think it's a good good thing that the
government is able to restore the phone
lines because people who were facing a
lot of issues they were not able to
communicate with their near and dear
ones but for some the worst restriction
is on freedom of movement shakes I hear
that's been teaching his niece and
nephew at home since the shutdown began
he says not being able to move around
has been severe there is still a lot of
problems here the kids are stuck inside
the schools have been shot in 3035 years
I haven't seen restrictions so bad my
sister is only two kilometres away and I
don't know her situation despite the
promise of the lockdown being loosened
some are protesting in other ways
Kashmir's have set up their own
barricades in this neighborhood to stop
armored personnel carriers from entering
them what you got Ivana we've put up
these blockades so that police won't be
able to come here and arrest the youth
they tried a few times but failed the
police are trying to come here but the
people are resisting we've managed to
keep them away many times acts of
defiance even as the Indian government
says it will take a wait-and-see
approach before lifting more of its
restrictions in the region as Jamil
al-jazeera New Delhi